hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play the
witch's house okay this plant is ashen
for some reason and there's a fire place
that goes into hell so let's go down it
why don't we I'm sure it won't lead to
my death like everything else in this
house yeah what does that sound whoa no
way I'm back it up what was that what
just happened a hole opened up in the
floor but I didn't fall into it that's
surprising okay so here's the bust of
the male figure the bust of a male
figure this is back where I was before
the bottles of wine everything is the
same way what's that oh it's just on a
chair okay hi-yah I try get back [ __ ]
how dare you don't you dare oh no you
didn't okay I'm right how about no okay
Everett terrific alrighty then okay open
the door to the chef's area is this Han
is this chef still cooking here have you
kitchen knife the handle is covered with
black sticky stuff door hi door stop the
fire do nothing let's do nothing how
about that is a big dragon work cuz I
haven't saved in a while you very much
hi handprint how are you doing
why okay I stopped the fire open the
door get on the floor everybody do the
darkness I don't know how I've always
latent ones hmm
this where's the brown source which one
hmm
wait hang on gotta make my neck longer
mmm I'll play like this the whole time
is that a brown source yeah okay thank
you okay I'm in a room full of bones
it's not very good for the atmosphere
Daniel okay I'm in a room full of bones
I need to find out why
here and why can't run while I'm in here
no the skeletons have hands oh that
makes so much sense considering the chef
wanted those hands okay so I can't let
go anywhere because it's just all
nothingness there's just nothing here
why am I here oh no I stopped the fire
he's not gonna like that okay
i heated pot smell smells odd doesn't do
much for your appetite look open the lid
probably a hand in there a LITTLEST pots
search inside you wouldn't do to dare do
that with your bare hands a wiener and
some cabbage are belittling inside okie
dokie smells like rotting pig guts what
what am I supposed to do okay so how do
I get is a big dragging mark on the
floor lined with the tableware I don't
have anything that could pull it screw
it I don't know why another hole opened
up in the floor okay that's fantastic
but what does that mean for me
cuz I don't have anything that I could
possibly do to open the damn thing door
slotted door not a door and I'm going
back up cuz I need something with which
to grab on to the device okay the chair
is toppled over can I go out here and
save thank you yes I can okay heard a
loud crash something happen yes why yeah
stop it stop it oh stop it okay anyway
so I need to find something with which
to grab the pot but I've known you maybe
put a glove on my hand I have no idea
what is over here
maybe there was like a doily oh the Hat
I can take the hat won't let me take the
Hat yes I'm looking for pot that's
exactly what I'm doing
yes okay whatever shut up
drugs are legal you did not do it can
you be officer Ned for a second Enoch no
I do not your drunk minecraft episode
it's pretty intoxicated Thank You
officer Ned wrong crew whoa what a
discolored vase okay there's still the
lady with the ring here I'm guessing
that I need to get the ring for the lady
from that pot of boiling something or
other I have no idea what though oh yeah
guys [ __ ] yo tow
okay they're leaving good finally some
privacy okay so now that we've got the
pilot and then we Han why wouldn't I do
that with my bare hands I've done a lot
worse stuff so I need to find like
something in here that has no okay
does it chopsticks that'll work
okay I got gold chopsticks fine I'll
take it
for what no thank you I don't want any
search inside how about with the
chopsticks search with the chopsticks am
I gonna find a ring well the chopsticks
cop
hi mr. skull hi I'm gonna leave now oh
crap oh crap why why is that why is that
a thing okay
hi mr. skeleton what's going on here
okay
skeletons are of all sizes none of the
skeletons have hands pile of skeletons I
don't think there's anything new in here
that I need
how do I get out of here okay that's
cool and all but can I go home and get
out and go on my merry way oh wait
there's a note return things to where
they are
how about noon pot of wiener and a
cabbage did I play I took the lid off
can I put the lid no golden chopsticks
no need for that oh I need to put the
chopsticks back Oh proper manners in all
that bull give me did you drop these
thank you
where put them in the eye socket yeah
okay good all right we're good now okay
we're not good deal are we good I don't
know yeah I did it
maybe oh crap no there you go come on
what I haven't saved it forever what the
hell oh man I've been saved in forever
shut up Vaz on a shut up okay so
apparently the eye sockets were not the
proper place to put the chopsticks oh
the chopsticks were in the skeletons
ribs
that's just how markiplier be markiplier
knows what markiplier needs to do to be
markiplier okay so I got to remember
that they were in the ribs not in
anything else do nothing put the
chopsticks in get the ring out put the
chopstick back okay got it
okay caught something hello mr. skull
yes I know you're worried about getting
your chopsticks back I will get you
those chopsticks are you listening to a
markiplier video while I'm making a
markiplier video yeah I was on the news
in case you guys didn't a long time ago
and accidentally was plows blanks under
the arrival beta and I swore I totally
dropped the f-bomb while I was on live
they're not live TV but on they're
recording me for TV so there we go okay
so now I can leave right yes I can leave
there's someone coming down the stairs
oh hi doggy oh he's alive oh okay you
want to like show the dog on the camera
for those who were worried I didn't
actually shoot this doggy bring him over
here cuz I click curve it up here I
didn't actually shoot this doggy he is
alive and well
he's burning lose him too like you gotta
get like over cuz like I'm actually dead
dumb you got to get over damn it goes
yeah get over closer let go yeah he's a
ghost
we're all dead and we're all powwowing
here in the cyndago headquarters down in
South Carolina okay oh you guys let's
all date our cousins and do moonshine
you heroin moon heroin are you humping
the dog oh why why why why the dog video
I'm a dog shooter why can't you be the
dog humper okay anyway I need to get
back my my ring okay I need to get this
lady back her ring put on ring if you
like I should have put a ring on it this
is my thank you okay cool now I can get
out of here door opened and now I won't
die what was that something broke she
broke why she got a ring and then fell
to pieces one she looked at me she
looked at me okay
this is why I need to backtrack to areas
right this is not a good hallway it's
not a good hallway to be in thank you
lady thank you I appreciate the assist
oh this is good okay that's not supposed
to be there that is that is in the green
spot pick up doll face doll okay so I
can only move one at a time obviously so
this is pretty pretty simple puzzle here
pick up doll put down doll pick up doll
put down doll pick up doll put down doll
pick up doll put down doll
click click okay got it I'm a genius and
so amazing everything I do
ooh we're in like a rose garden hello
kitty
yo seems like this is the top floor it
is and I almost dear to the end of the
game I might be I might be the beautiful
flower said to me how do you do elder
tree says do you need something yes
please there's nothing I can do for you
be silent [ __ ] on your knee elder tree
okay so there's a nice rosebush
artificial roses artificial roses that
like some sort of allegory to that this
is an artificial happy place and it's
not real and everything is an illusion
and my mind is going crazy
I'm not murder you and your sleeps or
not is that about not crazy
hey your subjunctive and don't make fun
of my okay shut up okay anyway so I'm
here and there's beds ooh a comfy bed
can I go nappy nap can I go sleepy sleep
can I get sleepy
stop making fun of me good done okay
large clock time marches on touch it ah
it squished me I died I died it all over
the place you can see my deadness all
over the floor
Boop
okay anyway we're continuing uh hole
opened up in the floor then the girl
came over to play a cute girl with
golden braids that's me I'm a cute girl
with golden braids y'all heard it here
first
okay now there's room down here then
going in
it's pitch black in here well what the
hell I wanted to go down there okay
whatever
so this girl that came over to play is
obviously me but what does that mean
that this witch's house I'm guessing
what I've pieced together so far is that
this girl is the witch and this is her
house and she's making the house do
these weird things to play with me the
flower ladies are beautiful and can
speak these are their characteristics
the white flowers are most beautiful at
the garden when touched by rain oddly
their petals glow the red grasses are
knowledgeable but they're always lying
so be careful when conversing with them
the yellow flowers are lovely to a fault
the pollen produced by these flowers is
a strong medicine that can kill or give
life interesting mmm yes how interesting
okay so where are all of these flowers
now there's somewhere else but I'm
actually all out of time for now I will
I may be approaching the end of the game
I have no idea so thank you all so much
for watching clicking in the future will
use it I've done and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye I can
tell you my MA
I was tired
ah
Oh God